vea el video completo antes de
administrarse una inyección de
anticoagulante
este video le enseñará a administrarse
una inyección de anticoagulante llamado
también diluyente sanguíneo
los diluyentes sanguíneos ayudan a
prevenir la formación de coágulos en los
vasos sanguíneos
antes de comenzar necesitará toallitas
con alcohol jeringa previamente llenada
con anticoagulante y una caja para
elementos cortopunzantes
las partes principales de la jeringa son
el cilindro que contiene el medicamento
el émbolo el capuchón de la aguja y la
aguja
para la inyección selecciona un lugar al
menos dos pulgadas a la derecha o a la
izquierda de su ombligo o en cualquiera
de los muslos
un asistente también puede utilizar
estas instrucciones para inyectarle una
dosis en cualquiera de los lados de la
espalda en la parte superior de los
brazos o en la parte superior de las
nalgas utilice un sitio de inyección
diferente cada día para evitar hinchazón
o hematomas
[Música]
además aplique su inyección a la misma
hora todos los días
asegúrese de seguir las instrucciones
del médico
no omita ninguna dosis no se inyecte más
medicación que la indicada
[Música]
primer paso antes de comenzar lávese las
manos con agua y jabón y luego sé que se
las
segundo paso limpie la piel del lugar
donde colocará la inyección con una
toallita con alcohol haciendo un
movimiento circular
paso 3 para abrir la jeringa retire la
lámina de aluminio de la parte posterior
no empuje la jeringa a través de la
cubierta de aluminio ya que podría dañar
la jeringa
paso 4 sostenga la jeringa de los dos
lados del cilindro a continuación tira
del capuchón de la aguja directamente
hacia afuera sin doblar la aguja habrá
una burbuja de aire en el medicamento no
presione el émbolo para expulsar La
burbuja de aire hacia afuera del
cilindro
paso 5 con la mano libre pellizca y
mantenga sujetada una pulgada de piel en
el lugar de la inyección
inserte la aguja en un ángulo de 90
grados a través de su piel y en el
tejido graso debajo de ella
paso 6 presione lentamente el émbolo
para que ingrese todo el medicamento
incluida La burbuja de aire paso 7
retire la aguja de la piel
paso 8 presione El émbolo con firmeza
hacia abajo para activar el dispositivo
de seguridad que cubre la aguja
paso 9 deseche la jeringa usada en la
caja de elementos cortopunzantes
llame a su médico si nota aumento de la
hemorragia hematomas erupción cutánea
entumecimiento u hormigueo especialmente
en las piernas
[Música]